et
il
notre vieille terre est une étoile ou
toi aussi tu brilles un peu je viens de
chanter la balade
la balade des gens heureux
j'ai connu une autre époque dans mon
époque à moi j'ai eu ce privilège là
déjà j'ai connu les foins la main j'ai
connu les moissons j'ai connu les
moissons quand c'était une fête où tous
les villages participer aux moissons des
uns et des autres c'était une fête mais
vraiment une fête enfin on se retrouver
ça durait jusqu'à 3 4 heures du matin
selon le le temps selon des tas de
choses et c'était vraiment une fête on
partait avec des paniers tout ça il ya
des gens dans la région dans qui font
des chaires 1 j'en ai l'occasion de
l'est chez eux
et puis salle elles ont plu aux enfants
celle ci était tout petit bébé
il ya des corps n'est pas l'eau c'est
encombrant les corners industriellement
maintenant commercialement c'est pas
valable
alors dès la naissance on leur met de
gouttes d'acide à la naissance des
cornes et puis comme ça on est on n'est
pas embêtés alors dans les abattoirs et
les choses comme ça c'est plus pratique
on gagne du temps maintenant le temps
s'est unifiée de l'or alors le temps
d'enlever des cornes de terreur c'est
triste mais c'est comme ça alors ce qui
fait que la pauvre à la pâte cornes
mais le petit l'appliquent appel on lui
a laissé ses cordes nous parce que on
aime bien ça finalement les bêtes
entières et tout avec tout ce qu'elles
ont oui mais
pour ça les met au fond
oui béthune pas
m
non
vous croyez qu'il ya un langage entre
vous les animaux je suis pas s'il ya un
vrai langage mais je pense qu'il ya un
ton il ya un ton est bien contacts et
les animaux simple très bien acquise en
affaires et vers qui ils sont ils
choisissent en fait les selon leurs
critères à eux qui sont des critères de
feeling quoi de contact de 2,2 sont je
crois que la voix est importante pas pas
les mots je sais qu'il ya des gens qui
sont complètement gâteux et mon chien et
comprend tout ce que je lui dis mais il
ya des échanges qui se crée il ya des
habitudes et on se comprend
voilà on donne de l'intelligence à ces
bêtes bon même parfois je n'hésite pas à
dire que nous nous bêtes sont
intelligentes
parce que si on se regarde un peu vivre
j'ai regardé un petit peu la façon de
vivre des hommes qui veulent à tout prix
se détacher de leurs instincts premier
donc par nature première sous prétexte
d'intelligence et bien avec le recul on
se dit que souvent les bêtes ont l'air
au moins aussi intelligente que certains
hommes et tout ce qui passe
comme mot c'est d'accord d'accord
pourquoi pas
d'accord d'accord d'accord je veux bien
aller rosie la copa cabana
d'accord d'accord d'accord même chez
désinvesti c'est des gens qui n'aiment
pas qu'ils me parlent en anglais des
trucs que je comprends pas suis d'accord
pour tout ça
si tu restes avec moi
des gens abandonnent abandonne des bêtes
et pour eux c'est un gadget presque si
tu restes avec moi
si tu restes avec moi
et des gens chats et des chiens et puis
il ya des gens chez un chat
et
et plus
la nuit il sera plus très longue
oui je sais que tu es qui sait
qui et c'est un soir il était une voix
une chose qui est assez étonnante je
touche chez les chats ce qui me laisse
le lobe de l'oreille en sapant des des
heures ça il vient de temps en temps
puis les déchets un petit peu comme ça
n'a pas de pedigree mais on s'en fout
complètement parce qu'il a beaucoup de
charme de fantaisie y ait trois ou
quatre
moi je finirai ma vie dans une ferme ça
c'est sûr
jaffa souris ou non je m'en fous
complètement parce que ça c'est un rêve
de gosse et moi les promesses d'enfants
c'est fait pour être tenu et non
seulement c'est pas pour tenir mes
promesses mais c'est parce que j'adore
ça
d'ailleurs si j'ai une basse-cour et
tout ça c'est parce que j'aime ça moi
j'ai été élevé comme ça et c'est une
c'est une occupation c'est une chose que
j'aime j'aime la terre j'aime j'aime
vraiment la terre moi ça me ça me gêne
pas du tout la terre quand je suis plein
de terre je me sens pas seule et dieu
sait pourtant si je suis maniaque et est
propre
et alors pour illustrer un peu l'idée de
ferme
vous avez pris une chanson qui se passe
apparemment aux états unis oui enfin les
états unis s'étaient nostalgie de d'une
certaine image de l'amérique qu'on a à
travers les mon enfance donc l amérique
c'était en grande partie le western la
grande plaine john ford john wayne bon
les leçons les cloches les symboles et
les les boeufs les troupeaux tous ses
carnets et sierre le soleil et l'image
du cow-boy solitaire qui part vers le
soleil coin vers l'ouest
le soleil rouge à brûler nos collines et
moi j'ai le coeur comme du verglas sur
la route de salina une fille
avec les mêmes cheveux blonds que toi
dit fait nuit
il veut voir solo
harry